el yo no con este panorama en mente del
poder de francia en términos militares
especialmente en medio la guerra en
ucrania cómo entender entonces la
reelección de manuel bajó de nuevo como
un alivio además de todo lo que usted
dijo también tiene obviamente la
potencia nuclear que es fundamental y yo
creo que es realmente el hecho de saber
que
estamos de nuevo en un gobierno
proeuropeo que quiere jugar en un equipo
que quiere hacer que todos los países de
la unión europea jueguen juntos y hablen
de una sola voz que actúen juntos porque
al final geográficamente los refugiados
que llegan a tal o tal país de europa
van a integrarse ahí hay espacio de
circulación de libre circulación de
personas hay espacio de libre
circulación de mercancía entonces la
realidad europea ya está aquí saber que
el presente de un país tan fuerte dentro
de la unión europea es de nuevo una
persona que es pro europea que tiene una
visión colectiva una visión
universalista del rol de francia es de
nuevo a nivel personal pero creo que
para muchos franceses que nos ven esta
noche un verdadero alivio